Hitler's ultimate target to the east was
to conquer the Soviet Union known as
Operation Barbarossa then he viewed much
of what's now Eastern Europe as a site
of repopulation for the Germans the plan
would have met the extermination of
people already there there was of course
a systematic massacre of millions of
Jews nearly all extermination camps were
located in Eastern Europe some scholars
estimate that almost half of the six
million Holocaust victims were Soviet
citizens camps were also established to
four Soviet prisoners of war the Nazis
acted with exceptional savagery in their
abuse of captured troops there were
shots they were experimented on with gas
or work to death more than three million
Soviet prisoners were killed most of
them by deliberate starvation one war
crime was for the hunt of about 500
Soviet officers who'd escaped from the
mouths thousand Nazi concentration camp
in Austria one of the witnesses to those
events was a lady called Anna Hackel
their family managed to save the lives
of two Soviet officers siren child they
drove around the villages with
loudspeakers and announced a dangerous
criminals had escaped and they needed to
be beaten stabbed or even shot it was
terrible
they described it as haunting them like
hares
[Music]
bring the captured Runaways back to the
camp dead
[Music]
who lived about ten to eleven kilometers
from the concentration camp and they had
the courage to reach out to us it's
scary and so he knocked on the door and
said please give me something to eat and
my mother took his hand and said I know
who you are she went to my father in the
bedroom and said father have you heard
one person has come here let's help him
you can't you know we will all be seized
and our whole family would disappear
forever
but my mother didn't give up later my
father eventually said do what you want
but you'll have to take responsibility
for us for the whole family she brought
me high into the kitchen and said I also
have five sons who went to war and I
want all of them to return home you also
have a mother who is waiting for you yes
he said and I also have a heart my
mother replied
[Music]
mom said I have not six but eight sons
we were one family we loved each other
they weren't strangers they were
brothers to me and together we really
felt good
that's how destroy okay mom talked about
it so fondly this baby hug me so tight
she went upstairs with my mother and she
had a religious icon of the Divine
Mother
the two women couldn't speak to each
other Wan didn't know German the other
Russian but the gestures she always
pointed to the icon and hugged my mother
again and again and then we found out
that she actually had eight sons and
only Nikolaj returned home
[Music]
you